There's pretty much a limited number of
factors on reasons why people are going
to upgrade to pay you for the service.
For us,
we had multiple tiers or pressure
points that we had set up in the plan.
It's going to be, for the early plans,
how many forms are you going to need,
if you wanted user management.
For example, if you were wanting to
have multiple people on your team have
access to the resources at hand,
you could easily charge by that.
How many entries or
data that you're going to process,
which made sort of sense and
then certain features that you wanted.
For example,
payment integration was one that would
only be available on the higher planes.
The idea was, the reason that you
stratify on all these different areas
is because different users
will pay different things.
In a product that was generalized as
Wufoo, there's lots of industries,
markets and verticals, different
people had different pressure points.
Our goal around the features was making
sure people got to try before they buy.
Seeing entries, being able to
build the form, that was fine but
like payment integration was only
available on a middle tier plan but
we wanted even free users
to be able to try it out.
We would figure out ways to say,
for five transactions,
you can try it out for yourself to
see what it's going to be like.
Having your own custom theme or
logo, people care very much about I
want this to be a part of my identity,
and it was a big difference for Wufoo.
What we tried to do was,
in all the different ways that people
might be pressured to upgrade,
we tried to build that inside of Wufoo,
and made it really obvious.
Then it made sense that most
people would send around
the first plan that had one
set of unlimited features,
which would be unlimited
forms on the middle plan.
The reason you also have
multiple pricing plans
is because you don't know what the
average revenue per user is going to be.
If you could predict ahead of time
that the average revenue per user is
going to be, let's say, $25, then you
could just have one pricing plan.
It's free and then it's going to be this
because that's about what it's going to
be and
that makes things a lot simpler but
you don't know what that's
ultimately going to be.
So you have this grid, it's why people
set it up, to capture that cost but
some people, again, if you're
going consumer versus going B2B,
people have different
price sensitivities.
For us, we thought it was like this
is going to be both consumer and
B2B, and that was the case for us but
it heavily skewed that most of
our paying customers are all B2B.
We had lots of people individually
using the free plans but
what would end up happening
is those people and
their free plans were our biggest
word of mouth growth people.
We made sure that Wufoo with the users
on the free plan, we made it easy for
them to talk about our services,
share with other people and do all this,
because that's who is going to be our
champions on the individual side.
On the B2B side, it's usually like
they're spending someone else's money,
someone else's budget, so
they're less price sensitive.
All they care about is does
this help me get things done?
A lot of the emphasis there is look,
with one click this is just going to
work, with one click you
are going to install this template,
with two seconds you are going to
have this feature ready for you and
you are don't have to
worry about this anymore.
It's all about that convenience and
saving of time, and it's no going to
cost you nothing, especially for
people wanting payment integration,
this is going to pay for itself really,
really quickly and
then showing that evidence of that.